- I almost can't believe
what I'm about to say next,
but it is true.
Jane recently threw some shade
at me, y'all, that's true.
- [Jane] I did.
- That's true.
I came across an interview
you gave, let's check it out.
- Who has shocked you as far
as being the most aggressive?
Like is there someone who maybe came on--
- Kelly Clarkson was just
completely off the charts.
- [Radio Host] That's very funny.
- She was, and she was
ordering everybody around,
she was ordering me around.
And she was--
- What a dream.
Honestly, I love her.
- She was kind of cheating,
and this was for Red Nose Day,
so we didn't have Standards
and Practice come down,
so she was just like, you know.
Like grabbing the bouncy
ball out of people's hands
and saying, "I'm gonna do that again."
And we allowed it, we allowed it,
because it was fun and it was good TV.
True!
(audience clapping)
- Jane is right,
this is a secret my family
only knows, and friends.
But I'm actually quite annoy,
well, and anyone that saw me
on "Hollywood Game Night",
either show, but I'm actually
a lot when I play a game.
- She's a lot.
- But I didn't think I
cheated, I didn't know.
Here's the thing, this is true.
- You don't know
whispering the right answer
into your partner's ear
- No, because I thought.
- is not cheating?
- No, I thought it was a
team effort from our group.
And then the one person
had to go run.
- Why would you whisper then?
Because you knew it was wrong.
- 'Cause I didn't want
the other team to hear me.
- Okay, well that makes sense.
- Yeah, I didn't want them to hear me.
- I'm gonna let you go with that.
- No, 'cause literally, I'm
hardcore on rules usually.
- No kidding, oh on rules, yes.
- You gotta, but now
next time if I'm on it,
you gotta bring out
flags, like on the play.
- Yeah, right, well, we
should've but you see,
this was Red Nose Day,
so we let people get away with this stuff.
But we have a Standards and Practice--
- Don't let us cheat.
- Yeah, okay.
So, you didn't wanna cheat?
- Don't let me cheat, I
want you to be hard on me.
- Okay, oh, all right.
Okay, well we've--
- Like a coach.
I was in sports, I can handle it.
- Okay, I'm gonna wear a whistle,
and I'm gonna go all Sue
Sylvester on your ass.
- [Kelly] I love it, be Sue Sylvester.
- Yeah, there we go.
(audience clapping)